exzessive dienst kommt nur leider war
unser weder nicht so sonnig wie sind und
so weiter im regen stehen wissen aber
mit regenjacken ist es dann ganz gut
gegangen
[Musik]
und da ist auflockerungen oder nur
lernen sehr verspielt und 1943 gefragt
und dort 70
das war zwar nach messer und die
lebensgrundlagen unterricht kommt doch
im fahrdienst an hoffen
beispiele zeigen filme geschaut und
haben ein ausbleiben dieser auswählen
lässt mich ein im alltag ruhiger ja
heute haben wir wieder offen ist ob da
haben wir uns die ganzen bereitschafts
gerade und die anschlagsorten gibt
ein sturm bildete dann der körper einer
rede zu verändern wird
in italien schlossen im schnitt halten
wir brauchen um eine gute form
[Musik]
[Applaus]